now to what's trending tonight is Ryan
Reynolds joins Stephen Colbert on The
Late Show yes he's in self-isolation
with his wife Blake there are three kids
who are five years old three years old
and eight months old plus his
mother-in-law oh boy but Ryan says he is
having a blast
this morning I made dresses out of
tissue paper it was fun for them yeah
nice not bad at all right what about
personal grooming obviously your star
you you're radiant with your own beauty
what are you doing about your own
personal grooming now that you're locked
inside tomorrow
Blake is gonna is gonna give me a
haircut she's done this once before yeah
it took two and a half hours and and
then at the end it looked like she'd
done the whole thing using only a
lighter or like or like those you know
those gloves that are made of sandpaper
it would have been a little faster my
she just wore it down but she just jar
my head until the hair just disappeared
hey listen Ryan I had to cut my son
Jackson's hair the other night now
granted there was a bit of a bald spot
in the back but I can help Blake help
you get this haircut going okay can you
can you really okay
that's Rogers pandemic Lana's like have
both been donating to charities
including 1 million dollars to feeding
America and to Food Bank Canada and now
it seems the 1 million dollar mark is
the go-to amount is Dolly Parton
announces she's donating that number to
Vanderbilt University's coronavirus
research department yes and Oprah is
teaming up with Apple and Leonardo
DiCaprio to launch America's food fund
go fund me forward slash America's food
fun and I'm gonna donate a million
dollars I hope you all will join me I
know everybody can't donate a million
dollars but I feel like this is the
central place to go and Oprah wasn't
done yet she's also donating an
additional nine million dollars to help
Americans and cities across the States
and in areas where she grew up such an
amazing
tribution